level 150 is where I am with all the
characters so I think I'll be ready for
the DLC well there's a point I'd like to
make with that here's the thing about
what I'm about to talk about
is the fact that it's kind of preference
on how you want to experience the DLC me
personally I want to experience the DLC
in its default difficulty how they
design the fight to be because the first
playthrough of anything whether it's the
DLC or the main game or whatever it is
in all of these games they're like a
sacred thing that can get they can get
messed up pretty quickly it's definitely
your preference on how you want to
experience the DLC because
usually in all of these games
they put the DLC in a unique spot you
don't just press play on the DLC and you
go immediately and play the thing you
sometimes have to go find it
they'll give you information on how to
find it but it's gonna be somewhere
random in the world and then you're
going to be put somewhere else I would
think just based on the the past games
and how they've released their DLC
they're gonna put the game or they're
gonna put the DLC
somewhere in the middle of your
playthrough it's not gonna be at the end
it's not going to be at the it could be
at the beginning I don't know it's not
gonna be you know you need to be level
150 or level 200 to even get through the
DLC it's probably not gonna be that so
based on your preference how you want to
experience it like if you just want to
run through the DLC really quick then
you've got your level 150 200 character
you go demolish everything
you get that experience whatever for me
I don't really want that I want to have
the default experience so how I'm
getting this character ready is I'm
probably only gonna go to about morgot
and then I'm gonna stop I might play a
little bit more just to level up a bit
more but I don't want to over level so I
I don't overpower the DLC that they
create the other part of this is for uh
people who have one character and
they're on New Game Plus
you're already kind of messing with the
difficulty when you go into New Game
Plus like because I think a lot of
people are on New Game Plus runs and
they have one character
if you're in new game plus six and you
go into the DLC you're gonna be on new
game plus 6 DLC it's gonna be new game
plus whatever the number for your DLC
experience which is something I don't
want I want to have the default what
from software designed and how much
damage they do the default experience
whereas like two or three of my other
characters are on new game plus three or
whatever so that's why I'm making a new
character and I think that's why you
should too
if you haven't played the game in a
while or you only have one character at
new game plus whatever you should
probably think about leveling a
character to about 75 maybe a hundred I
don't know exactly where the DLC is
gonna be but like I said just based on
how the other pass games have done DLC
it's gonna be somewhere in the middle of
the game the middle of the experience so
I'm gonna try and have that most genuine
default experience that from software is
going for I think I'm gonna have a
better experience with it but that's my
preference like I've been saying like if
you just want to roll through it and
that's your experience good for you
um if you want to experience the DLC on
new game plus six
go for it man I'm bad enough it'll be
hard anyway then that's fine
that's fine what if they make the DLC
scale to in-game stuff then you can go
to your main character
this is more like the reason I'm making
a new character is just in case because
here's what's gonna happen
I I'm a little bit scared of this exact
situation happening DLC is gonna release
there's a whole bunch of people
that are new to these games
that don't know how DLC Works in these
games it's very different from past from
other games so like with dark souls 3
DLC the first DLC was about halfway
through the game and it scaled to
halfway through the game do I think
they're gonna do that with elder ring
I don't know that's why I'm being
cautious in making a new character isn't
it a little early for a new character
for DLC I don't know we haven't received
any information they usually release DLC
for their past games I'm going based off
all the past stuff all of their past
games which I think makes sense to go
off what they've created before and how
they sort of handle these things right
it could be very early for me to make a
DLC character I'm just kind of getting
it ready I think people do that in World
of Warcraft right like they prepare for
new expansions
that's kind of what I'm doing for Dark
Souls 3
they release DLC in October when the
game released in March with bloodborne
nine you guys are saying nine or eight
eight months we're getting pretty close
to that I think it's coming if it's
gonna come it's gonna come soon
if it's not it's gonna be mid next year
which yes could be a little early for
this but I'm just I'm being cautious I
want to have uh I want to have my
character ready to go there's a lot of
new people in these from software games
playing that don't understand what we've
been just talking about right they're
completely new to the franchise and they
only know Elden ring so they're on new
game plus six
they've got a character that's level 400
and they haven't even beat the game yet
they're gonna get the DLC that they're
gonna pay for probably 20 to 30 dollars
for this DLC they're not gonna get the
experience that they thought they were
gonna have like they did in their first
playthrough when they were leveling
through the game and they're gonna get
pissed they're gonna go on Twitter
they're gonna start some [ __ ] on Reddit
they're gonna be like well this is just
so I had such a bad experience and I
can't have this first experience ever
again I see it coming people are gonna
get mad because they haven't played
other games they don't know how the DLC
Works higher level players will blow
through the DLC quickly and then
complain that it wasn't enough
exactly what I'm saying there's gonna be
people out there and you know these
people exist it they're they're out
there man they're gonna be level 500 or
whatever the hell they're gonna go into
the DLC and be completely disappointed
they're like this wasn't difficult at
all probably because you were level 500
they start arguing people start arguing
it goes on forever it's super [ __ ]
annoying all I know is that the DLC will
be great you're absolutely right the DLC
is always the best content in all of
their games dude maybe aside from ashes
of Arendelle
I like Dash's very indel in Dark Souls
3. ring city was clearly better but I
really enjoyed all of it it's always
good dude always good I'm hoping to go
in a bit under level for the DLC and
take my time with the bosses and
properly learn and appreciate them if
that's the experience you want to go for
then you should get ready for that and
I'm kind of warning all of you now that
you should get ready for it they could
go down any route with this DLC we've
been talking about that for months at
this point you know like all of the
potential DLC routes that from software
could take with this game so I don't
know what they're gonna do but whatever
they decide it's gonna be sick I I know
it and I do hope it's pre-shattering
before everything went to hell and we
can talk to like Queen America like you
were saying that would be amazing that's
exactly what I want I don't know if it's
what we're gonna get but that would be
cool I'm going based off the past games
past experiences because that's kind of
what happened to me when I played Dark
Souls 3.
I was super overpowered I was new game
plus seven on Dark Souls 3 when ashes of
Arendelle came out
so my experience was completely
different to how a default experience
would be through the game I guess what
you would actually really want to do is
wait for DLC to come out
and then start a new character but this
game is different from the past games
like you're saying
so what I'm suggesting is that you guys
should prepare yourselves for the DLC
and not want to start a new character
when the DLC comes out because this game
is absolutely [ __ ] massive
it takes a long time to get everywhere
that you want to go it takes a long time
to get all the items that you need for
the weapons that you want stuff like
that if you want that proper default
experience which is preference like like
I've been saying I just want a battle
pass do you really want to battle pass
guys I just want to talk to America me
too that would be cool what I'm
suggesting this is all I'm saying is
that you might want to start a new
character
so that you can prepare yourself for
whatever happens so like if it turns out
you want to be level 150 you got a
character right there you're ready to go
if it turns out it's supposed to be mid
game then you have a character right
there ready to go for that if you need
to be
whatever the hell
400 you got a character ready to go for
that you think they would connect Elden
ring with other games to the DLC
if that's the route they want to go they
definitely can as of right now there's
no reason to think about I don't think
the games are connected until they prove
to me otherwise
as of right now the games are not
connected the other thing to think about
is I wonder
if the endings will change based on how
you play the DLC I don't know if they're
gonna add more endings or
the way you play a DLC will affect an
ending you just gotta prepare yourself
through all of this to you know make
sure your experience doesn't get trashed
which I think people will complain about
anything and everything
so I'm just throwing this out there is
anyone else surprised that they haven't
at least updated the coliseums yet I
feel like we were talking about that
four months ago and nothing they haven't
done anything yet
I find that very strange
I feel like that's such an easy update
to get people at least some people back
into the game again this is worldwide
Google Trends of Eldon ring of people
just being interested in the game yes
this graph is very very normal
but you guys know that there would be a
little rise in this graph if they
you know put out the update for the
Coliseum PVP
people would come back and they'd they'd
try that especially if they put like
ranked in this game somehow I don't know
like that sounds really difficult in
these games that just seems like such an
easy win to have out there you know like
open the coliseums
and have ranked PVP like that's how you
get players playing the game is you have
a multiplayer with a competitive system
if you want this graph to like shoot up
to at least halfway and stagnate it
halfway I would say the equivalent of
steam is probably PlayStation and Xbox
combined maybe I think so but it's just
increasingly down every month so I guess
when you just beat the entire game you
don't really have a reason to keep
playing it unless you update your games
which
they have not been doing the coliseum's
not being updated yet makes me afraid we
aren't getting DLC at all that's
something they could have patched at
launch DLC is certain for sure I can't
see from software being that stupid
business-wise bloodborne
one of people's most favorite games of
all time millions of people love
bloodborne it had one DLC it's still at
30 frames per second they could put out
a 60 FPS patch for sixty dollars and
everybody would buy it just for how good
it is we might complain that that's kind
of a you know kind of a lot but I would
pay it I'd do it
I would it's that good of a game that's
an easy dub that's an easy millions of
dollars if they make it ten dollars they
will make millions of dollars
if they put bloodborne on PC if they
made it 60 frames per second if they
updated the game in any way shape or
form for however much money they wanted
they could do that I think there's some
legal things going on with bloodborne
right now but I'm not 100 on that
that is an easy dub and they did not do
it sakiro another example
Sakura won game of the year in 2019 was
very successful video game that
everybody loves the combat system of
everyone loves the story of it no DLC
for Sakura in three years nothing
besides a Bosch Rush Gauntlet which is a
cool update but was free and have not
touched the game since maybe it didn't
need DLC maybe bloodborne didn't need
more DLC but this kind of goes to my
point I don't think from software gives
a [ __ ] about money so while Elden ring
and the deal in making DLC for for it
might be just the easiest dub business
wise
I don't think they care they want to
make quality ass video games
that's all they care about quality over
quantity and yeah it depends on the
Publishers as well like Activision Sony
I'm sure there's a lot going on there
especially with bloodborne not being on
PC because that's an easy dub put that
out for 60 bucks on PC that's tens of
millions of dollars guaranteed with how
massive Elder ring is and how successful
it is I don't think it's crazy they can
do all of that they absolutely can I
remember reading an article where Elden
ring blew away their expectations they
expected 2 million sales in I believe
the first month based on their previous
games and they sold 14 million blue will
weigh their expectations they may have
just made enough money with this game
man they want people to keep talking
about it and theorizing on everything
because that's kind of how these games
work Miyazaki has said many times that
he doesn't like making sequels to games
the only reason Dark Souls 3 exists is
because Dark Souls 2 exists Dark Souls 3
would have never existed if Dark Souls 2
didn't exist which he had no involvement
in at all
I think some involvement but he was not
the creative director now do I think
that they will make DLC of course
they I think they will they've like you
said they've made DLC for all their
previous games except for sakiro was
their game of the year which Elden ring
come on guys it's gonna win game of the
year
unless Ragnarok
Elden ring should win game of the year
agreed it should it probably will Sakira
won game of the year and it was like
their [ __ ] side project while they
were working on eldering so
my point on that is I don't think Chrome
software cares about the business they
don't care about how much money they
make because they know that whatever
they put out is a [ __ ] banger
they could just make another game that
has nothing to do with Elden ring could
be another sakuro another bloodborne
like type of game not bloodborne 2 or
sakiro 2 but a whole other game
they know they make bangers that's all
they do people are gonna buy it they
want the quality experience
that's all they care about I still think
they're gonna make DLC of course I hope
they do but I don't think it's out of
the realm of possibility that they don't
foreign
[Music]